Analogical reasoning allows us to look at new problems in terms of familiar
problems. It also allows us to transfer knowledge from familiar problems
to new problems. A hierarchy process of analogical reasoning is shown here.
It consists of five major phases, retrieval, mapping, transfer,
evaluation, and storage. We'll discuss all five stages, in detail.
Let us compare for a moment, the process for an illogical reasoning in general,
with a process for, case based reasoning, within domain and
illogical reasoning that we discussed earlier. Notice that retrieval,
evaluation, and storage, are common between the two processes.
In case based reasoning the target problem and this first case,
were from the same domain. They had the same kind of relationships, and
the same kind of objects. We simply had to adapt the source case to address
the target properly. An analogical reasoning in general, the target form and
the source case need not be from the same domain.
When they are not from the same domain, we can't just take the source codes and
adapt it. We first have to map the target problem with the source case that is,
we need to address the correspondence problem. What in the target problem,
corresponds to what in this source case as an example? The laser beam and
the target Duncker's radiation problem corresponds to the rebel army in
the source case. Once we have mapped the conceptual relationship in the target
problem to the conceptual relationships in the source case, then, we can try
to transfer some of the relationships in the source case to the target problem.
We can first abstract those relationships and then transfer them to
the target problem. As an example, the Duncker's radiation problem we
first did the alignment, that is, we just did the correspondence problem,
what in the target [UNKNOWN] corresponds to what in the source case?
Then we took the relationship, and abstructed it. The relationship in that
case was, take the resource and decompose it into several smaller resources, and
send them to the goal at the same location. That particular relationship, that
particular pattern, is what we abstracted and transferred to the target problem.
Note that this is just one theory of analogical reasoning. In other theories,
some of these boxes are configured differently. For example, in another theory,
mapping is a part of retrieval. We do mapping in order to do retrieval.